alors que les steen parmi les régions
qui pourraient être concernés par cette
interdiction il y à certaines plages de
belle île mais cela ne toucherait que le
sud de l'île effectivement ce sont les
sites les plus sauvages qui sont touchés
sur bélisle des plages courtisé l'été et
même si les équipes de nettoyage
travaillent d'arrache-pied pour que tout
soit propre d'ici fin juin
c'est la plus grande incertitude alors
belle île qui luttent contre le pétrole
et qui souffrent de cette image des
plages souillées
c'est ce qu'a perçu notre équipe avec
laurence faux et joël gauthier toutes
voiles dehors la plage des grands sables
reprend petit à petit des couleurs
les classes de mer s'en donnent à coeur
joie et les premiers baigneurs se laisse
tenter par l'eau claire ici sur la côte
nord de l'île
philippe prépare son matériel pour la
saison c'est plutôt cette image d'une
faute propre que beaucoup d'habitants de
lille aimerait que l'on retienne et nous
celle des plages souillées ya des gens
qui souhaitent pas qu'on en parle il ya
des gens qui souhaitent qu'on en parle
beaucoup
les cas de figure sont envisageables
c'est comme face à un événement
dramatique dans une famille
certains se referme d'autres souvent à
l'extérieur mais le mal est encore là en
dizaines de tonnes ramassées dans des
sacs ou encore échoués sur les plages de
l'autre côté de l'île la côte sauvage
samuel arpente régulièrement ses criques
et ses plages il ne peut faire qu'un
triste constat dès qu'un coup de vent de
sud-ouest soleil la mer ramène le fioul
c'était bien de moi quoi ici c'est tout
propre
c'était impeccable on va dire qu'un jour
on va maintenant que ça fuit
officiellement à ça revient se fait
comme c'était pas officiel ça revenait
pas régulièrement
lille est sur les nerfs sur le port
toujours les mêmes questions les mêmes
incertitudes nul ne sait pendant combien
de temps ces arrivages
dans ce pack sur 101 stress présent chez
les gens on se méfie on a peur c'est
c'est pénible coin moi je disais 5 on
nous avait volé l'hiver
en hiver nous on se repose on se
retrouve entre nous on va à la chasse à
la pêche aux champignons
on nous vole l'hiver le printemps est là
économiquement on nous vole l'été quoi
votre vie a été bouleversée par ce soit
le stress sur believe
car ils sont toujours là ces hommes en
combinaisons blanches au travail depuis
maintenant six mois des appelés du
contingent qui nettoie galets après
galets plage après plage comme de la
chirurgie esthétique mais la bataille
contre le pétrole n'est toujours pas
gagné on a des gisements de pétrole si
on peut dire qu'ils vont jusqu'à à peu
près de 1 m 20 soûles et sous les galets
coin donc on décaisse les galères on a
décaissé les galets du bas de la plage
si jamais devant on a décaissé décaissé
décaissés et ça fait comme dans un
millefeuille vous avez 40 cm de galles
et 20 centimètres de pétrole 40 fois
qu'une aide légale et 20 centimètres de
pétrole la menace acteurs mais aussi une
autre menace que les autorités n'avaient
pas prévu à 50 mètres des falaises par 5
mètres de fou les plongeurs de lille
découvre du fioul il a fini par couler
et maintenant ils se déplacent par
endroits il est enterré mais peut se
découvrir avec leur sac quand la
température augmente
il commence déjà à remonter à la surface
les plongeurs observe avec inquiétude
son évolution sans connaître de renom et
même plus des galettes scellé
des nappes de table c'est les soucoupes
volantes même c'est ça représente
plusieurs mètres carrés samina toute la
faune et de la flore est-ce que ce port
dû se dilue avec avec la mer avec l'eau
les filtreurs entre les animaux
filtreurs attrape tout ça mange tout ça
ces filtres heures sans manger par bob
être un petit peu plus grosse et puis ça
rentre dans la chaîne alimentaire comme
ça et ça finit par nous attend bélisle
sous pression retient son souffle
si le pompage et chief elle est la
première sur la trajectoire des nappes
de fioul l'épave délicat et juste en
face de la côte souvent